dans l'actualité ce soir des grèves mais
pas de jeudi noir la journée d'action
contre la réforme des retraites a
rassemblé entre 300 et 700 mille
manifestants selon les sources le
conflit les pêcheurs n'est pas terminée
à marseille dans l'eau nous sur la côte
atlantique les marins ont repris le
blocage il juge le plan daide
insuffisant le réquisitoire au procès
fourniret sans surprise le procureur
demande la perpétuité incompressible
contre michel fourniret perpétuité aussi
contre son épouse monique olivier avec
une peine de sûreté de trente ans
l'affolement sur le marché du pétrole
accélère le retour en grâce de l'atome
vingt ans après l'italie annonce qu'elle
va renouer avec le nucléaire
et enfin ne parlait plus de chirurgie
mais de médecine esthétique comblement
des rides injection ma mère les
traitements légers sont préférés et se
banalise c'est le dossier de cette
édition
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous cette
journée de grève contre la réforme des
retraites avait valeur de test
au final comme souvent chacun voit midi
à sa porte pour les uns c'est un succès
pour les autres les manifestations n'ont
pas fait le plein à paris où l'on a
compté entre 28000 et 70000 personnes
dans la rue reportage fabien shadow
samuel dumez du monde
indiscutablement vais sans doute pas
autant que ne l'espéraient les syndicats
sur le pavé parisien ils étaient entre
28000 selon la police et 75000 selon la
cgt parmi eux beaucoup de retraités ils
ne seront pas touchés par la
modification de la loi mais il met en
cause le niveau des retraites trop
faible selon eux pour vivre correctement
j'aime travailler 42 ans et plus pour
l'occasion le front syndical était uni
toutes les organisations pour répondu
présentes ont refusé le passage de 40 à
41 ans de cotisation pour une retraite à
taux plein la journée d'aujourd'hui je
crois naturellement que s'il ne change
pas d'opinion
cette journée un tel raz du sol sur le
dossier des retraites l'emploi des plus
de 57 ans est le seul point que le
gouvernement accepte de discuter des
défilés étaient organisés dans 120
villes au total images ici danger de
bordeaux et aussi de grenoble je vous le
disais chacun a fait ces additions pour
la police
les cortèges ont rassemblé 300 mille
personnes au total pour la cgt sept cent
mille des manifestations et des grèves
aussi les perturbations sont restées
limitées c'est à marseille que le trafic
a été le plus perturbé sur place marie
laure guerrier et christophe la rocca
trains bus métros
quand l'un ne fonctionne pas on compte
généralement sur les autres mais
aujourd'hui à marseille c'était bien
plus compliqué un tgv sur deux en
direction des villes de province un
corail sur 2 lagalère habituel un coup
c'est les ans le lendemain c'est les
autres et à l'arrivée c'est toujours la
même team of quoi on fait grève comme en
très grave alors on arrête tout une
bonne fois pour toutes
réponse des cheminots qui manifestaient
ce matin à marseille aujourd'hui à ce
que les mécontents parce qu'on a pas de
transport wasquehal est mécontente de la
politique est menée dans notre pays qui
qui a produit la population c'est
sérieux de choisir c'est pas moi retard
dans les trains qu'à cela ne tienne
direction le métro à paris avait pas de
grève non rideaux de fer baissés les
deux lignes étaient arrêtées jusqu'à 15h
doit passer un examen de ses repères et
dans une heure je sais pas comment je
vais faire là donc
donc il ya pratiquement 100%
il ya quelques bus qui fonctionne alors
extrêmement rares le bus donc lorsque
l'on en voit passer un mieux vaut ne pas
le rater
mais sous les pas et il reste encore la
plage certains ont pris du rct
d'autres ont séché les cours ailleurs le
trafic a été conforme aux prévisions
plutôt moins perturbé que d'habitude
images ici de paris et de
l'ile-de-france où les effets du service
minimum se sont également fait sentir
a la sncf les grévistes doivent se
déclaraient désormais 48 heures à
l'avancé du coup la direction a eu le
temps de s'organiser la circulation a
même été un peu meilleur que prévu
on écoute ses commentaires de voyageurs
saisi au vol dans les gares avec un
train sur cinq
mais par contre au niveau des métros ça
se passe très bien c'est comme une
journée normale ses yeux qu'elle fait
suppression mais
dans l'ensemble ça se passe bien là je
suis venu une demi heure en avance aussi
de voir une classe matisse dans le train
du retour perturbé mais
c'est moins pire que la vague précédente
organise un petit peu mieux c'est de
mettre en place des horaires informé un
petit peu mieux usagers malgré tout
quand même otages est tributaire du bon
vouloir de ce monsieur c'est quand même
pas normal
propos recueillis par jean yves blanc
sachez qu'on a compté 27 % de grévistes
à la sncf
9 % dans la fonction publique et à la
poste ou encore 14% à edf
vous le savez l'un des arguments des
syndicats c'est qu'il ne servirait à
rien de reculer l'âge du départ à la
retraite alors que la plupart des plus
de 55 ans ne travaille pas il est vrai
que les entreprises qui embauchent les
seniors sont rares il vient car bernie
mériaux micheline barbier vend des
lunettes
l'an dernier elle a dû quitter son
précédent travail et rechercher un
nouvel emploi
à 51 ans vous étiez un petit peu
inquiète quant à votre avenir est très
angoissée par il ya eu quand même la
période
on s'est dit qu'on va retrouver à partir
d'un certain âge qu'on va retrouver
vraiment du travail à notre niveau
micheline barbier a eu de la chance
l'entreprise qui l'a recruté favorise
l'embauché des seniors pour diversifier
la composition d'équipé très jeune mais
pas seulement avec les seniors par leur
maturité par leur expérience apporte
quelque chose et en plus par rapport à
nos clients qui eux mêmes sont seniors
l'a véritablement il ya un lien qui se
crée et commercialement parlant c'est
très important mais les entreprises qui
adoptent une telle démarche sont bien
trop rare et le chômage des seniors est
devenu un fléau chez les 45-64 ans on
compte plus de 500 mille demandeurs
d'emploi auxquels il faut ajouter tous
ceux qui sont dispensés de recherche car
trop proche de la retraite près de
quatre cent mille personnes
un scandale pour jaxaay italie ancien
chef d'entreprise de 59 ans qui cherche
depuis quatre ans déjà
au début quand vous cherchez un travail
vous êtes enthousiaste c'est au fur et à
mesure que vous perdez la pêche pour
retrouver parce que il n'ya pas
d'entretien et parce que on vous le dit
pas où on vous le dit l'âge on vous
envoie la figure l'âge d'une manière ou
d'une autre
donc on ne servait plus à rien pourtant
les seniors sont souvent très qualifiés
cette bénévole les accompagne dans leur
recherche d'emploi
mais pour elle les entreprises ne sont
pas demandeuse on entend souvent des
remarques c'est le salaire bon alors
vous êtes surdimensionné c'est à dire
que vous avez trop d'expérience au trot
de qualification ça peut être aussi des
gens qui préfèrent avoir des gens format
table 1 je prends un jeune qui sort de
l'école parce que je vais pouvoir le
former à je veux dire la politique ou la
stratégie de mon entreprise augmenter
l'emploi des seniors le gouvernement s'y
est engagé il se donne même un an et
demi pour aboutir à des résultats
jusqu'à présent tous les efforts
entrepris
tron ont échoué autre conflit qui
perdure celui des pêcheurs dans beaucoup
de porc les propositions avancées hier
par le gouvernement sont jugées
insuffisantes
les représentants nationaux des marins
ont été désavoués les blocages ont
repris cyril à catherine juste valeur
et le blocus se durcit au guilvinec des
câbles tendus pour empêcher l'accès au
port les bateaux resteront à quai ici
les mesures de soutien sont rejetés en
bloc tout comme à la rochelle pour les
marins le compte n'y est pas 0,40 à la
pompe autre chose et pas question de
lever les barrages avaient accepté par
la communauté européenne manche
atlantique méditerranée dans la plupart
des ports le mouvement est reconduit
seuls les pêcheurs de royan roscoff
l'île d'yeu et le croisic ont repris la
mer les assemblées générales se sont
succédé à boulogne on hésite le geste du
gouvernement a convaincu certains
patrons l'état s'engageait à compenser
la perte de salaire des hommes au delà
de 40 centimes d'euro c'est quand même
une belle avancée sociale ces 40
millions d'euros mis sur la table au
niveau national voilà un argument battu
en brèche par la base des grévistes
voeux du gasoil je le mets dans mon
balade dans les bouches du rhône
les dépôts pétroliers occupée par les
marins ont été évacués des marins qui
attendent la semaine prochaine le
soutien de leurs collègues espagnols et
italiens qui resteront également à quai
dernière précision sur le sujet l'aide
française d'urgence pour compenser cette
hausse du gazole n'a pas reçu le feu
vert de la commission européenne
russell vous le savez et veille à ne pas
fausser la concurrence vis-à-vis des
autres pêcheurs de l'union la mesure
française est en train d'être examiné on
en vient à l'actualité judiciaire le
procès de michel fourniret et de monique
olivier touche à sa fin c'était
aujourd'hui l'heure du réquisitoire le
procureur a donc demandé la perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté
incompressible contre le tueur en série
présumé perpétuité également à
l'encontre de son épouse avec une peine
de sûreté de trente ans sur place daniel
verdoyant bruno vignais
depuis cinq ans l'avocat général porte
ce dossier à bout de bras je n'en peux
plus de ces horreurs dit francis nachbar
alors ce sont des mots que l'on entend
rarement dans la bouche d'un magistrat
keaton aux assises vous êtes des
monstres des faits les pauvres malades à
gervais fournirait à gerber monique
olivier mais surprise avocat général
redistribue les rôles il y a le
pitoyable petit fourniret et à côté la
sorcière l'égérie la muse du crime sans
elle dit le magistrat
rien n'aurait été possible l'avocat de
monique olivier a l'impression qu'on a
changé de procès c'est un réquisitoire
contre monique olivier et qui dédouanent
michel fourniret de tout ce qui est en
bien c'est pas vraiment une surprise
pour nous puisque nous fournirait
et à strictement aucune discussion est
donc tout l'effort a été axée sur
monique olivier perpétuité réelle sans
remise de peine possible requise contre
fournirait à perpétuité avec période de
sûreté de 30 ans contre son épouse
le maximum prévu par la loi la moindre
des choses selon les parties civiles
en face de 7,8 mort de viol d'état on ne
peut rien mettre en face on pourra
mettre toutes les peine qu'on veut ça
n'atténuera jamais plus de cinq heures
de réquisitoire durant lesquelles les
deux accusés ont offert des visage de
marbre
michel fourniret a fermé les yeux sans
broncher monique olivier a baissé la
tête
tentant de se faire oublier dominique
verdeilhan qu'on retrouve en direct
devant le palais de justice bonsoir
dominique ce réquisitoire a
particulièrement retenu votre attention
ah oui le chroniqueur judiciaire que
nous sommes sont assez surpris par ce
ton c'est vrai que ni guy georges ni
francis heaulme ni pierre bodein
j'allais dire n'y ont eu droit à leur
expliquer que c'est un ton qui vient de
la part d'un magistrat qui dit ce qu'il
a sur le coeur
face à des accusés qui depuis huit
semaines et bien joue avec les nerfs de
la cour d'assises
il y en a un qui a fui son process et
michel fourniret bouche cousue je parle
je ne parle plus il ya celles qui a fui
ses responsabilités
c'est monique olivier alors c'est un ton
qui a plu aux parties civiles
mais c'est peut-être un ton aussi qu'ils
étaient là pour faire oublier que dans
le passé et bien michel fourniret avait
bénéficié des défaillances de
l'institution judiciaire
merci dominique le rapport annuel de la
halde la haute autorité de lutte contre
les discriminations a été remis
aujourd'hui c'est un thermomètre la
halde créée il ya trois ans est de plus
en plus connu et reçoit donc de plus en
plus de plaintes 6220 réclamations l'an
passé contre 4000 en 2006 motifs de ces
discriminations l'origine suis pas très
loin le handicap viennent ensuite l'âge
et le sexe
et c'est dans le domaine de l'emploi
qu'elle est le plus souvent constaté
voici un contre exemple une démarche
volontariste et qu'il faut le souligner
se révèle probante
on avait évoqué ici même cette
initiative des grands palaces parisiens
pour donner une chance
offrir un stage aux jeunes des quartiers
qui s'étaient portés volontaires
et bien c'est un succès sur vingt jeunes
qui la main a été tendue 17 ont obtenu
un contrat pierre monnet gier christophe
kenck
quatre jeunes de seine saint denis face
aux patrons des plus prestigieux palaces
du monde
je suis très fier je suis très fier
parce que cette opération pas la citer
il était d'aller c'est aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure du bilan ses fruits en syrie
vous êtes engagé comme maurice resteront
le d'avis cyril la moniz wissam et
mohamed
tous ont décroché leur cdd nous les
avions rencontrés en mars dernier
pendant quatre mois mohamed a été formé
par un champion du monde de pâtisserie
lui qui ne trouvaient pas de boulanger
prêt à le prendre en apprentissage
wissam vendait des kebabs
le voilà commis de cuisine sous les
ordres d'un chef étoilé
tous ces jeunes étaient en difficulté
chômage petit boulot dans leur quartier
l'avenir leur semblait bouché l'univers
du luxe
un autre monde quand on est rentré pour
la première fois dans cet hôtel on s'est
dit mais est ce qu on réellement silésie
faire puisque c'est vraiment la grande
classe quoi aujourd'hui ils sont bien à
l'aise dans leurs costumes et se
prennent à rêver
c'est d'ici cinq ans
j'ai mûri sous du matin dit en même
temps j'ai plus la même personne
j'ai remarqué c'est à dire qu'est ce qui
a changé
la gestion des comportements sur vingt
stagiaires 17 ont été embauchés les
hôtels qui les ont accueillis sont
conquis ces jeunes auraient quelque
chose de plus que les autres les marie
chantal houle et jean edouard
n'ai pas envie de prendre les servières
n'ont pas envie de prendre un ballet
n'ont pas envie de travailler le samedi
le dimanche et n'ont pas envie de
travailler après 20 heures
la région ile-de-france qui a financé
leur formation va renouveler
l'expérience et l'élargir à d'autres
secteurs
en bref une famille fauché sur un
trottoir à marseille aujourd'hui en
bordure d'une voie rapide
la mère et son fils de 3 ans ont été
tués par une moto de grosse cylindrée
qui avait elle-même été percuté par une
voiture
le nourrisson qui se trouvait dans la
poussette a été grièvement blessée la
conductrice de la voiture très choqué a
été placé en garde à vue
comment lutter contre le hooliganisme
à deux jours de la finale de la coupe de
france de football et à deux semaines de
l'euro un nouveau phénomène mobilise les
policiers alors que les débordements
sont généralement maîtrisé dans les
tribunes les supporteurs les plus
déchaînés se retrouve maintenant loin
des stades
la nouveauté c'est que ces bagarres
parfois larmes blanches sont planifiés
organisée attention si des enfants sont
à vos côtés certaines images peuvent
choquer enquête franck genauzeau
mattioni veng love qui sur les bords de
la loire d'un côté 80 hooligans nancéen
de l'autre le même nombre de nantes et
ils se sont donné rendez-vous à l'avance
loin du stade pour en découdre
l'un d'eux filmé la scène affrontements
à mains nues même nombre de combattants
de part et d'autre interdiction de
frapper un homme au sol
les règles se veulent précise elles ne
sont pas toujours respectées le
phénomène vient d'europe de l'est où les
combats sont minutieusement préparée et
souvent très violents
sur cette vidéo allemande
on voit même les hooligans de francfort
s'échauffer tranquillement avant
l'assaut
quelques minutes plus tard un des deux
groupes s'enfuit et on relève les
blessés on se tape sur l'épaule le fight
est officiellement terminée rares sont
ceux qui acceptent de témoigner dans une
forêt d'île de france
rendez vous est pris avec fabien 32 ans
hooligans parisiens il participe à des
faillites depuis plusieurs années marié
deux enfants un travail table située en
bord de rue quoi on sait sur ces
violences et incompréhensible pour
l'opinion publique mais on se fait mal
uniquement des gens qui ont envie de se
faire mal entre guillemets des gens qui
sont d'accord sur les règles des gens
qui sont d'accord en venant on n'impose
rien à personne et ça nous permet
d'enlever l'image de on s'en prend aux
femmes et aux enfants dans les tribunes
parce que l'ugtt manière en ce bas loin
d'êtres humains parmi eux selon lui des
ouvriers des ingénieurs et même des
policiers
un point commun leur club qu'ils disent
défendre qu'est ce que vous cherchez
danse et fight l'adrénaline
le rendez vous entre potes la solidarité
que paient entre murat fight
et puis c'est un délire qui coûte moins
cher que veut faire les sports comme le
parachutisme du motocross ou ce que vous
voulez quoi
et le goût de l'interdît un petit peu
quand même interdits mais surtout
dangereux comme cette bagarre sur le
front de mer à antibes en novembre
dernier niçois contre parisien la veille
du match
l'un d'eux chute du haut d'un muret sur
la droite de l'écran
c'est inconscient pendant de longues
minutes il sera conduit à l'hôpital dans
un état sérieux comme quatre autres
parisiens ce soir là les niçois n'ont
pas respecté les soi-disant règle ils
sont venus armés de briques et autres
projectiles
cette idée de compétition
d'affrontements physiques sans
conséquence mais c'est pas sans
conséquences on peut avoir des blessés
graves et avec des gens qu'on leur vie
brisée pour quelque chose qui à un
moment leur semblait important mais
franchement est ce que parfois vous
n'avez pas peur de blesser quelqu'un ou
tué quelqu'un a lancé fight blé fait
quelqu'un sait que ça va arriver il faut
cacher un verrou brahim arcade voir une
mâchoire mais de la tuer on sait que
c'est possible le mec en face que très
bien tomber sur la tête sur un trottoir
ça on est conscient mais eon cette
manière les risques comprend donc on
assumera à quelques exceptions près le
phénomène touche tous les clubs de ligue
1 mais aussi désormais ceux de ligue 2
et de national cette saison
les policiers ont recensé 18 fight et
plusieurs dizaines de blessés
l'économie l'affolement continue sur le
marché du pétrole le baril a encore
gagné 3 dollars à 135 $ et plus personne
visiblement ne s'y retrouve déclaration
rarissime du secrétaire général de
l'opep
le marché est devenu complètement fou
dit il s'est envolé n'est pas sans effet
après beaucoup d'autres l'italie annonce
aujourd'hui qu'elle va revenir à
l'énergie nucléaire et il y avait
renoncé il ya vingt ans après l'accident
de tchernobyl
le nucléaire qui n'a jamais connu un tel
engouement partout dans le monde
frédéric manca et sylvain aubin il avait
promis durant sa campagne
silvio berlusconi relance le nucléaire
il s'agit d'un revirement total après
tchernobyl
les italiens avaient totalement
abandonné l'option nucléaire les quatre
centrales du pays étaient alors arrêtés
aujourd'hui
l'italie rejoint les cinq autres pays
européens qui projette une bâtisse déjà
les réacteurs de demain ailleurs dans le
monde
d'est en ouest les projets se
multiplient aujourd'hui la planète
compte 438 centrales en activité
soixante et une centrale commandés et
159 projets à l'étude
le nucléaire ne fait plus peur aux
décideurs programme électronucléaire il
refleurit un peu partout dans le monde
la plupart du temps d'ailleurs sur la
bas
deux pays qui ont déjà des flottes parce
que ça permet de produire beaucoup
d'électricité à partir de peu de matière
première de maintenir domestique et sans
émettre de co2 la france compte profiter
de ce marché en pleine croissance
elle vend ses centrales comme ici en
finlande le groupe areva qu'il est bâti
devrait embaucher cette année douze
mille nouveaux collaborateurs
à propos d'énergie et de pétrole nicolas
sarkozy effectué demain une visite en
angola 16 millions d'habitants un pays
grand comme deux fois et demie la france
après des années de guerre civile c'est
le symbole même de l'afrique qui gagne
avec un taux de croissance complètement
fou de plus de 30%
il faut dire qu'elle est presque
entièrement alimenté cette croissance
par le pétrole l'angola possède
d'immenses gisements envoyés spéciaux
dominique derda frédéric ranque pour se
rendre à son bureau sur le port olivier
laurendeau part de chez lui aux
premières lueurs du jour passé sept
heures du matin ça devient
c'est bien plus ému que les temps de
trajets sont modifiées pour ses
conquêtes à luanda la capitale de
l'angola du matin au soir c'est le grand
embouteillage la preuve par le chaos que
l'économie du pays se porte mieux que
jamais 35 % de croissance landais
olivier laurendeau et le représentant
d'une pme française ponticelli dont la
spécialité est la fabrication et
l'entretien de tuyaux de vannes de
soupape pour l'industrie pétrolière
l'envoie là pour sa société comme pour
les autres est un pays de coca quand
tout le monde est repris forcément il ya
de la place pour les autres comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
la fortune de l'angola 7 à 150 km des
côtes et par 1500 mètres de fond qu'il
faut aller là puiser un exploit
technologique pour les ingénieurs de
chez total qui ont fait ce pays le
quatrième pays producteur africain
derrière l'algérie la libye presqu'à
égalité avec le nigeria sous cette
gigantesque barge grande comme trois
terrains de football 45 kilomètres de
tuyau relié à 23 puis arrimé au fond de
la mer dans les cuves jusqu'à deux
millions de barils de brut
tous les deux jours un super tanker
vient faire le plein et repart en
direction de l'europe de l'amérique ou
de l'as les réserves par est inépuisable
on a déjà estimé ses réserves
comme très importante
je pense qu'on est vraiment qu'au début
de cette phase destination
je pense que
l'avenir le dira mais je crois que ian
ford cette scène en moi je n'utilise
attendant après 27 ans de guerre civile
et six années seulement d'une paix
retrouvée l'angola bien besoin des
milliards de dollars que lui procure son
pétrole à luanda partout des grues des
chantiers ce sont les chinois qui
rappelé la plupart des marchés et se
font payer en liquide
c'est en noir dont nul désormais ne peut
se passer mais dans les quartiers
pauvres comme celui de prenda on attend
toujours de voir les effets bénéfiques
du pétrole
le taux de chômage dans ce pays et de 60
pour cent et l'espérance de vie dépasse
à peine les 40 ans voudrait nous faire
croire que tous les angolais aujourd'hui
sans riche puisque notre pays riches
mais pour les autres nous qui a les
moyens et qui roulent en voiture combien
marche tantôt relié à la paix grâce à
l'argent du pétrole l'angola pourrait
bien vite devenir l'un des pays les plus
développés d'afrique à moins qu'ils le
suivent l'exemple de ses voisins le
gabon le congo brazzaville ces
républiques pétrolières dont les
richesses profitent surtout à
l'insatiable caste au pouvoir
toujours à l'étranger c'est une première
le secrétaire général de l'onu ban ki
moon a effectué aujourd'hui une visite
en birmanie
entretien de 20 minutes tout juste avec
le premier ministre survol des zones
dévastées
les autorités lui ont affirmé avoir le
total contrôle de la situation
le diplomate visiblement peu convaincues
indiqué que sa priorité était de
convaincre les généraux d'ouvrir plus
largement le pays à l'aide
internationale
apparemment il n'a pas été écouté la
visite en france de taslima nasreen
c'est un symbole
la romancière du bangladesh et menacé de
mort par des militants islamistes
elle s'est vue remettre aujourd'hui le
prix simone de beauvoir pour la liberté
des femmes
renaud bernard ça faisait lui même ici
seuls les caméras sont braquées sur elle
mais même à paris taslima nasreen reste
une écrivaine en danger je sais que
beaucoup de monde depuis un petit
peut-être aurai-je dieu et si je
retourne en inde beaucoup dans mon pays
natal mais je peux aussi mourir en
europe
taslima nasreen cible des fatwas des
islamistes pour une dizaine dé ces deux
romans de recueils de poèmes consacrés à
l'émancipation des femmes
dès 1994 sous la pression de la rue
cet ancien gynécologue doit fuir son
pays natal le bangladesh nouvel exil il
y a deux mois d'inde là bas ses
opposants lui jette des bouquets de
fleurs en pleine figure
d'autres plus radicaux mettait a pris
sept mille euros je critique la douille
le 6ieme le judaïsme le bouddhisme mais
n'ont jamais voulu me tuer seuls les
fondamentalistes musulmans veulent me
tuer les visites vous croyez aux droits
de l'homme aux droits de la femme de l
islam les femmes souffrent cruellement
trahi et l'on sait pas si cela à force
de fuir taslima nasreen a obtenu la
nationalité suédoise
mais là bas aucune protection à paris
c'est différent gardes du corps et
voiture blindée
et quand elle se rend au quai d'orsay
elle entre par la grande porte
reçue comme une personnalité par rama
yade hommages de la république avec le
prix simone de beauvoir un bref répit
avant que taslima nasreen ne soit obligé
de fuir encore vers un nouvel asile la
politique en bref on évoqué hier la
réforme des institutions 17 députés
socialistes et apparentés dont manuel
valls et patrick bloche ont lancé un
appel dans le journal le monde en faveur
de cette réforme sous réserve
d'amélioration le parti socialiste selon
eux ne doit pas se soustraire à ses
responsabilités et rester dans une
opposition systématique la santé on le
sait on le regrette parfois l'apparence
physique l'esthétique prend une place de
plus en plus importante dans nos
sociétés jusqu'à présent la chirurgie
était surtout mis en avant aujourd'hui
un nouveau marché est en pleine
expansion
les traitements légers comblement des
rides injection ma mère la médecine
esthétique se banalise avec un chiffre
d'affaires
a multiplié par quatre en dix ans c'est
le dossier de cette édition il est signé
laurence beauvillard bernier mériaux
laurence n'aimait pas ses seins pas
assez de volume
il y à un mois elle a essayé une toute
nouvelle technique sans chirurgie une
injection pratiquée à l'heure de la
pause déjeuner en vingt minutes
le médecin a fait deux injections par
fin et on a ensemble décidé du modelage
on va dire et la proportion est l'effet
a été tout de suite instantanée autre
cliente avant et cinq jours plus tard un
bon résultat mais les médecins mettent
un bémol il faut surveiller ses
premières patientes et gaieté
d'éventuels effets secondaires
parfait donc massés sous le beauf comme
ça cette méthode
autorisée depuis janvier dernier suscite
un engouement énorme
les spécialistes sont rares est débordée
par les demandes
le produit utilisé ces de l'acide
hyaluronique
c'est une une injection de volume sur
mesure à l'endroit où on veut entre la
glande et le muscle la technique coûte
5000 euros avec une piqûre de rappel
tous les 18 mois
car le produit résorbable et les fait
diminuer la demande en médecine
esthétique légère a été multiplié par
huit en dix ans et peu importe le prix
la technique la plus pratiquée c'est
l'injection de botox pour traiter les
pattes d'oie la base du nez et le front
ses 250 à 400 euros
autre possibilité pour combler les rides
c'est encore de l'acide hyaluronique
ce produit est aussi très efficace sur
certaines parties du visage
alors les sillons un peu les pommettes
d'accord et les lèvres pour à sion pour
dépôt m je vais prendre quelque chose à
l'acide hyaluronique et paix est
confisqué aux hits est importante pour
que le produit reste bien en place
je peux le faire alors que pour les
lèvres il faut quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fluide est beaucoup plus fin
les prix sont libres on facture à la
seringue 350 euros pièce ici la patiente
a réglé deux seringue
résultat immédiat pour un effet naturel
vous sentez
oui deux clients sur trois sont des
clientes
mais les hommes réclament aussi leur
droit à la beauté ici épilation
définitive de la barbe ou laser à 100
euros la séance
mes parents bon c'est parce que c'est du
bien-être et du confort donc c'est
normal que comme sont vachement
coiffeurs sont attardés le 1er
restaurant on assure aussi nos frais de
ville ce centre est le plus grand
d'europe
il y a des lasers pour tous des petites
veines que l'on supprime un tatouage qui
disparaît des traces d'acné que l'on
efface les techniques cher qui nous
promet d'être plus beau plus jeune plus
longtemps
l'environnement nous vous parlions lundi
de la sécheresse en espagne les
rotations de bateaux en provenance de la
france ont commencé le premier est
arrivé à barcelone hier pour livrer de
l'eau potable
ça va continuer pendant trois mois
ensuite une autre solution est envisagée
et préparé même une usine de dessalement
d'eau de mer qui va ouvrir donc dans
quelques mois
partout dans le monde ses usines se
multiplient pour répondre aux besoins
alors comment procède-t-on est-ce la
solution miracle réponse
agnès monte françoise maso c'est un des
endroits les plus arides au monde
l'arabie saoudite et pourtant ici se
trouvent ces jardins verdoyants et ses
piscines luxueuse
un miracle qui vient de l'eau de mer
transformer comme par magie en eau douce
dans 10 usines comme celle ci elles
fournissent 95% de l'eau potable de ce
pays pionnier l'histoire a aussi
commencé dans les petites villes il ya
une trentaine d'années comme l'île de
sein sans cet or bleu l'eau douce pas de
tourisme possible petit à petit deux
technologies se sont affinés le filtrage
le sel est retenu par différents filtres
ne reste que l'eau douce ou le chauffage
qui produit de la vapeur d'eau
débarrassé de son sel trop lourd
le coup a baissé et le réchauffement
climatique assèche de plus en plus de
régions dans le monde
alors sur tous les continents on trouve
maintenant de ses usines et le marché
devrait doubler d'ici dix ans 40% de la
population mondiale
van vy pardon à moins de 100 kilomètres
d'une cote demain l'inde du sud la chine
de l'est
voilà les régions qui vont
progressivement tout s'équiper d'une
usine de dessalement un procédé tentant
97 % de l'eau sur terre est salée mais
souvent polluants la désalinisation
produit beaucoup de gaz à effet de serre
et le sel excédentaire est rejetée dans
la mer
35 kg selle par mètre cube d'eau traitée
on risque d'avoir une modification de la
chimie de l'eau de mer et ça ça va
mettre en danger les organismes marins
qui vivent particulier dans la zone
côtière qui est un milieu extrêmement
fragile des milieux déjà fortement
abîmée par l'urbanisme et la pollution
le dessalement de l'eau de mer n'est
donc une solution partielle pour avoir
de l'eau douce
l'idéal c'est encore de mieux protéger
ses réserves l'italie elle a été
confrontée à des inondations soudaines
dans la banlieue de rome des centaines
de personnes ont été surprises par de
fortes pluies et de grosses et une
brusque montée des eaux hier soir les
autoroutes à l'est et au sud de la ville
ont également été touchées un nouvel
immortel l'historien de l'art et ancien
directeur du musée picasso jean clair de
son vrai nom gérard régnier fait son
entrée à l'académie française il a été
élu au fauteuil de bertrand
poirot-delpech disparu en novembre 2006
autre distinction céline dion a reçu les
insignes de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur des mains de nicolas sarkozy
tout à l'heure à l'elysée la santé
russes étaient prévenus pour les
recevoir la légion d'honneur dans ce
palais de l'elysée et de vaud mais
monsieur le président est un honneur
bien important
pour une petite québécoise de
charlemagne com - cela prend des
proportions et un sens qu'il est
difficile d'exprimer il ya une rencontre
entre l'admirateur le fan votre fan et
le président de la république est
vraiment je pouvais dire qu'en 2008
magie des corps et céline dion quand
même le festival de cannes avec le
retour de steven soderbergh ancien palme
d'or on s'en souvient avec sexe
mensonges et vidéo c'était il ya presque
vingt ans il présente aujourd'hui une
fresque monumentale sur che guevara
incarné par benicio del toro à cannes
pascal deschamps michael cariou un
réalisateur américain des acteurs de
toute l'amérique latine est un film de
4h30 en langue espagnole pour raconter
le tce le défi était autant politique
peu cinématographique
pour le monde entier le che c'est avant
tout cette photo qui a fait de lui une
icône sur laquelle le film apporte un
éclairage inattendu quartier n'est pas
une biographie filmée auquel hollywood
nous a habitués c'est un récit intimiste
et réaliste de ses années de guérilla à
la bourre j'ai lu plein de livres
rencontrer des gens qui l'avaient connu
des pro et des anti ché mais plus je me
suis rapproché de lui et plus j'éprouve
et de respect pour lui je ne me suis pas
sentie chargé de le démolir le porter
aux nues je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir les
mêmes idées que celui dont je refais le
portrait ce qui me frappe chez lui c'est
que deux fois
il avait tout quitté pour mener son
combat colza pour des tee-shirts de lui
c'est un symbole mais là on découvre
lettre u c'est bien parce qu'en états
unis on ne fait pas vraiment aux
publicités sur le tce
il quitte le gouvernement cubain et
disparaît brusquement un film qui pose
en effet une question mais qu'est ce qui
pousse un homme à quitter le pouvoir
pour reprendre les armes et en mourir
seul et loin des siens
idéalisme ou aveuglement idéologique
chacun jugera
c'est non nous rappelle tous quelque
chose qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas ils
nous ont fait parfois denses et vous
fait rire boney m les village people ou
patrick hernandez les dinosaures du
disco reviennent sur scène ensemble et
c'est en france
le coup d'envoi de cette tournée
exceptionnelle à rtl disco show était
donné hier soir à nantes au libellé nous
à yann moines étaient dans la salle
un concert aux allures de bal costumé
vieilles cartes ou remonte au siècle
dernier
il y a trente ans plastic bertrand lui
est toujours aussi jeune
rose joue un personnage complètement
pour moi c'est comme si on faisait du
théâtre là un théâtre avec son décor et
ses tubes
une production de 2 millions d'euros
l'un des acteurs principaux l'homme à la
canne à la belle époque quand ses
admirateurs le croiser il ne lui disait
pas bonjour mais c'était de me dire oh
c'était devenu un gimmick total de
prononcer bornes comme ça
un tube écrit en 1978 qui rapporte à
patrick hernandez 1500 euros par jour
encore le disco et la france une longue
histoire
le groupe le plus loufoque village
people est certes né à new york mais
créé par un parisien
c'est vrai qu'on parle de revival essais
mais en fait moi je pense que le disco
n'est jamais mort réellement en tout cas
depuis 15 ans maintenant 18 ans le
couple tout autour du monde
une tournée 15 concerts 75 du
spectateurs attendus une musique le
disco et des costumes pas prêt
finalement d'être remisé au placard une
image de football avec la victoire de
manchester united hier soir face à aux
londoniens de chelsea en finale de la
ligue des champions 3e sacre en 40 ans
il y avait un partout au terme des
prolongations
on a vu le premier but signé cristiano
ronaldo pour manchester voici
l'égalisation de lampard pour chelsea
qui peut avoir des regrets après deux
occasions manquées 6 à 5 finalement aux
tirs vous et vous l'avez vu ciel
malheureux nicolas anelka qui a manqué
le dernier penalty avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres des grèves mais pas de
jeudi noir en france aujourd'hui la
journée d'action contre la réforme des
retraites a rassemblé entre 300 et 700
mille personnes selon les sources
le trafic dans les transports publics a
été conforme aux prévisions relativement
important malgré ce mouvement d'action
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi sous suite la météo tania
yom point route valérie maurice 20h50
envoyé spécial autour de guilaine chenu
et françoise joly au sommaire notamment
une enquête sur les pcb ces polluants
qui contaminent des cours d'eau et
menace notre santé très bonne soirée
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
votre